three days of mourning is underway in
Crimea for the victims of Wednesday's
college massacre which left 20 people
Dead's mostly teenagers the killer then
fatally shot himself
the first funerals are being held in the
city of Kerch from where Marat Gustav
now reports thousands and thousands of
locals have turned up for this ceremony
a final chance to say goodbye farewell
to all those whose lives were cut short
in this horrific massacre just the
stress most of the victims were
teenagers aged 16 to 19 making their
loss so much more cute so much more
painful a lot of grief here people as
well as top officials the governor
turned up to offer words of support to
the families you understand one relative
felt so aggrieved so poorly that she
needed medical attention a little
earlier but the governor and others wish
them strength to deal with this tragic
loss nevertheless hopes and prayers here
with those still in hospitals many
people fighting for their lives in
critical condition on life support
battling severe injuries as I reported
earlier there was nothing spontaneous
about this Massacre it was coldly
calculated and pre-planned
[Music]
it was here on the 13th of October that
Vladislav Rossler cove the suspected
shooter began to turn his plan for mass
murder into reality and the 150 shotgun
shells he bought here only for the
second part of his atrocity we should
understand the commune document the
enemy probably from actually Prabhupada
new production patron : p an additional
150 shotgun shells were only for the
second part of his atrocity four days
later he waited until his mother left
this house dressed in black and carrying
a bag of ammo Rossler Cove
left for college on the other side of
town first he detonated an improvised
explosive device
second elastography literally the bomb
field as it was with lethal shrapnel was
set and triggered in the cafeteria on
the first floor exactly at lunchtime
when it would be packed with faculty and
students this was no crime of passion
lise was planned with cold calculation
given the effort needed to learn how to
and to actually build a bomb with a
timer or detonator the aim was clear to
kill and maim as many as possible as
quickly as possible in the ensuing chaos
as panic and confusion took hold the
gunman began his killing spree he
started on the second floor making his
way downstairs to the devastated
cafeteria killing anyone he met staff or
students
more shots more victims she owned a
Polish Creek you order a torch
instruction
madruga central there come most of them
teenagers they try to run to hide they
did desperate things video producer - a
covert Aslam on an idea his rampage
lasted just 15 minutes before he killed
himself in the library on the second
floor 15 minutes but his victims are in
the hundreds for every child left dead a
family was torn apart for every teacher
he killed generations of graduates left
stunned their friends than teachers
neighbors and countrymen all shocked and
hurt since the early hours of the
morning they've come here bringing more
and more and more flowers candles toys
and tears mourning a loss a tragedy that
they can scarce comprehend what's worse
a tragedy apparently without cause or
reason Marat gas D F with the report
while investigators are currently
combing the crime scene disturbing
pictures show blood-stained walls and
furniture and wrecked classrooms we're
terrified students tried to avoid the
gunman's bullets well with funerals
underway the pain of what happened is
still raw for the witnesses and the
survivors
[Music]
Staubach don't put it right now
besides the peaceful finally comparable
me she is a token privilege after all
with us
the Elizabeth
[Music]
see double thumbs up which I did eh -
yeah
Paulie Picasa make [ __ ] and get the
was vivica that somebody posted it for
my team but on the additional profit of
my scooper
yep because what I should need
[Music]
I said you know
bunch of people
here
[Music]
Octopussy
the episode polish Patel 15 your photo
language
Kodama
stop the authorities
you